going I hear wolf of Wall Street's on
the docket and so is object gone are the
days of viral videos of a side effect of
YouTube and Facebook and all these
social media networks kind of becoming
insular and disconnected from one
another so what does that mean obviously
this self content that we are totally
known for is 1 to 3 minute who will be
effective video game related video but
the problem with that for us is that has
always relied on that viral edge the
entire model is changing and we're gonna
be adapting to it incredibly proud of
all the videos we've made on our channel
and I think they're all super cool
they've made me who I am but the content
we want to create on YouTube now is
longer content it's what we got into
this whole thing in the first place
maybe 10 minutes long we're talking
about original series we're talking
about stuff that has a lot more value
more than just a minute or two of cool
apps and that's it that also means we
are going to change up the way we work
kind of wit and brands probably gonna
start seeing less and less of custom
videos where we actually work with a
brand directly to make that part of the
content of the piece and instead create
a clear divide between what is sponsored
and what is branded and what is original
content so this video here is a really
good example now that Sam has talked to
you about branded integrations on this
channel and sponsorships and how we're
going to be reproached that I'm going to
give you a demonstration right now
that's right you have entered a
sponsored message territory in this
video but if you little counter in the
top corner here in the screen this
sponsored message is brought to you by
the game best fiends forever it's a
third game the best fiends trilogy and
the way you play this game is you match
the screen as fast as you can if you
deal damage you've all these different
guys dealing damage here also you try to
build them up you level them up in fact
you pretty much level everything up in
the game so yeah just go crazy tapping
the screen making money and everything
goes up exponentially so like first
level you're making a thousand gold
coins second level you're making a
hundred thousand third level a million
this is kind of really satisfying
actually they like to say it's the most
fun you'll have with your fingers game
is free download there's a link in the
description below it's on both Android
and iOS big things to the best fiends
for ever team for sponsoring this video
really appreciate it if you guys saw the
video on coretour today
I actually did get lit on fire a roman
candle burning ball hit my beard in the
mess scarf and everything a little
intense really fun though that's the end
responsible
back to your regularly scheduled
Samaniego programming well it seems like
we're gonna be filming a Amina style
video parroting some fantastic Oscar
award-winning movies is object so far
I've killed all but Sam and Nico of
corridor digital I'm hoping to get an
entire corridor digital killstreak and
being on time
you're following the reason
I know you're up there there you go
[ __ ] I want an entire can I want
[Music]
[Applause]
project is a creative idea that Sam and
Nico have come up with through some of
their creative talks over time why are
we doing it now we had an opportunity to
do a trailer on the front of one of our
videos for best fiends forever the
problem was we didn't have any other
original videos that we could put that
in front of so we had to come up with a
concept and shoot a video in one week
and since this is a bit more of the
practice we're going to be employing
next year where we focus more on the
writing and on the shooting and on the
execution of a video rather than on
trying to make one-off viral concepts
without what better time to start doing
that then right now the lights walking
out to bring our own lights in and the
Turks are making a very small blue cast
which I don't think is we're gonna be
reading on our you know it's reading
that like oh well it's written it like a
1/4 so once we get our lights up and get
our camera balanced I think we're gonna
we're gonna not see so much that blue
let's see more of fans face and by Ben I
mean Sam and you that is a light meter
an incident light meters an incident
light meter tells you it gives you a
pretty precise calculation on how much
light is in the room it equates it out
to f-stops or shutter or an ISO
depending on what uh what setting you
have it on that way you could tell what
light is going to be showing up weird or
what's gonna be underexposed or
overexposed and you give you can you do
it all without ever even looking at a
camera
put in some heavy diffusion this light
because LED is since I have a lot of
different points can cast a very very
small micro shadows in there so the more
diffusion you have in front of it the
less likely it'll be that these shadows
will oh we got to keep those lips nice
and moist
after the story is that there are meme
traders or about to short the meme
market and the question is how
[Music]
well hopefully that does the trick
are you doing losing a couple personable
bouncers just Adam okay would be needing
all the Catalina listen I don't know
about this you know having worked with
Boyd points that even count
nikka buy this [ __ ] up
oh my god working so Sam and I well okay
so getting to do this Agreement sunset
and the only way to solve those
disagreements quickly and efficiently
it's my use of a wild card you can play
it once per day on the shoot circles
about to happen Sam and I have a
disagreement on which shop we want to do
for ages wait wait why are you giving it
to me okay I'm just giving it to the
[ __ ] world are we doing we're gonna
back off a little bit more we're gonna
we're gonna get kind of in the middle of
the two-shot still with the nice soft
background cool and that's gonna be what
we're gonna do because I pulled a wild
card and camera is salt hopefully don't
hit unsubscribe because that means we
won't be able to hear from your gun
we're writing scripts for bigger
projects features series and now that
was a YouTube kind of supporting an
environment for bigger Longer content
we're gonna try and start making that
for our main channel here on corridor
our mean video here is completely
original it's free of branch there's
nothing we're not trying to sell you a
single thing in the video but as you can
see there is a personalized shout out
that we're doing for those for this
brand because they are funding the video
course icons throw we have an avenue to
make longer cooler videos that bring
more value to you con we don't get to
make crazy random one-off videos that
are two minutes or three minutes and
visual effects Pro and we get to dig
deeper into storytelling which is
ultimately what people like to watch con
I get to do lots of the effects and
music based videos and it's gonna be sad
Pro everyone gets to go home early or
way like con everyone might have to go
home really really late here's the thing
you see we haven't started this yet we
don't know another huge Pro we're gonna
be trying to release one video a week
Renne
hopefully if we can keep Wren doing the
same amount of the effects but spread it
out over that amount I'm I feel like
each shots gonna be that way cooler the
thing is when you when you watch 20 VFX
shots back-to-back you don't go to each
one go holy crap holy crap holy crap you
know but if you have 20 shots and one of
them is a crazy be a better shot then
you say holy crap